é
[Música]
a gente começar a fazer num mensagem
vocês são produtoras de energia
se você analisar o custo disso ainda
mais caso você pegar um homem de 45 anos
[Música]
e hoje está passando por uma nova
revolução
é algo que mexe substituir trabalho e
energia um ano especial a gente vai
começar a nossa condição de geisy
inteligência artificial
isso acontece já as nossas vidas por
exemplo e comédia
o youtube seja uma pessoa a história de
todos o especial é mais fácil em com o
passar do tempo é mais o som
[Música]
outro exemplo é na área de saúde é um um
grupo de pesquisadores de marketing está
usando é especial pra fazer diagnóstico
de câncer de mama e dois milhões de
postos criados a partir de imagens são 5
milhões de casos por ano
alguns só com uma foto você pode tirar
e ele tem
talvez a mais importante seja os autos
ao ano
hoje no mundo face um milhão e meio de
cópias por ano em 25 anos está mais uma
vez que é um processo que está
acontecendo em todo esse período
exigindo assim e fala é uma coisa que a
gente tem dificuldade de conceber o
impacto disso porque as coisas de uma
maneira muito muito intensa
é desde a década de 40 até os dias
atuais a gente tem um crescimento da
ordem de dezembro
então pra vocês terem uma noção se você
fala começado por exemplo se o mesmo se
a taxa de crescimento aconteceu esse
cuidado a gente estaria dirigindo o
carro saiu da luz ou na segunda guerra
mundial estava alguns milhões de dólares
foram muitos e tal então a tecnologia e
[Música]
é e ainda muito
as obras o primeiro
[Aplausos]